neue informationen zur impfung nämlich
für alle die unter 30 jahren sind für
sie soll nur noch eine band tag impfung
in frage kommen die ständige
impfkommission die stiko hat genau das
jetzt bekannt gegeben es gibt nur noch
eine impfempfehlung für den impfstoff
bayern tag für alle menschen unter 30
jahren in deutschland auch moderner ist
jetzt raus denn vermehrt sollen der
herzmuskel und herzbeutelentzündung
aufgetreten seien bei der impfung von
moderner für unter 30-jährige also
astrazeneca aus moderner raus nur noch
bei und tag für alle unter 30 hier in
deutschland so die ganz aktuelle
empfehlung der stiko der ständigen
impfkommission ganz schneller kommentar
dazu poulsen jagt das chaos geht weiter
es ist keine politische frage sondern
das ist eine frage die eu kommission
entscheidet nach ihren erkenntnissen und
eben keine parteipolitische frage
zu der man parteipolitische antworten
können aber wissen sie auch ihren sparen
genügend bei und tag im stoff zur seite
gelegt hat für unter 30-jährige um
richtig zu ostern jetzt auch damit also
all diese informationen sparen
informiert die öffentlichkeit regelmäßig
so wie das die bundesregierung tut und
die hat auch die richtigen antworten für
sie